Oh J Stearman didn't I just see J sermon
in real life I found right I assumed I
found let's play J Stearman high-quality
chess so I'm delivering the more chests
that people asked for and now and then
I'll do I'll do the geoguessr okay
playing actually a serious player yeah
we we we met in st. Louis and it was
mostly Scrabble talk in st. Louis but it
was fun okay we have a London ooh
Queen b6 this is what this is what AG
Justine played against me in some form
he took first and then played Queen b6
it should be similar though threading
that a4 also might be five ideas
yeah this line is very dangerous for
black because I'm also threatening this
I've so many ideas my Queen b6 is
typical but okay it's gonna get
interesting
I'm threatening a fork oh he did a
coaching video with bowties mm-hmm oh I
think I saw that I saw some part of it
this is gonna get really weird because
I'm my King's gonna be exposed but maybe
I'll win a Brook maybe I'll win two
rooks Jack and I'll probably bonk loud
for the wind or am I just meeting my
just meeting Jack queen g4 check wait
this is very close to meet queen g4
opponent strong player though so I can't
get to carry the way Queen g4 Keeney 756
takes calculating queen g4 I mean this
is all forcing then queen h5 idea to
play Queen takes g5 and there's king
I mean Bishop e6 there's Queen Daisy six
King g7 King G 798 King h6 Bishop f4 g5
Queen take g5 mates let's go
it starts with queen g4 I think it's
first mate bishop wait I have to
remember the line yeah bishop here
there's well there's some other
deviations but for example King takes f7
and then this there's also kicking f6 I
assume everything gets mated
this will be really nice if it works
let's go I just realized my opponents
username we have a let's go emotes and
sometimes we have Leitz gooey meat Scoob
it's from Kentucky but this is very nice
coordination like the the minor pieces
created a nice beautiful wall now Queen
takes d5 and the key move ninety eight
to force the king this is exactly what
the calculation was if King f6 98 is
just meat oh there's one more line
Bishop e6 this is I forgot to calculate
but I assume it's somehow winning oh
about Adam the Queen that's not quite
winning yet hmm oh but I have Bishop c4
in some line wait this is getting weird
now I also have Queen g7 interesting
move
I can also sack both rooks and just play
Bishop c4 so many options not enough
time takes takes Queen d7 okay let's
start with this
[Music]
puzzles I did puzzles other day and it
was puzzling but maybe but first I want
to sack both rooks somehow oh that
doesn't work
wait is this meat no it's not me yet
yeah what do I do
check check there wait this is
eventually gonna be made to check check
what still not meat well is this
witchcraft check I'm not seeing it I
don't know why I played that can you to
delay barcloud no oh no this is really
bad
No
I'm not winning this Oh this position
was so good but I took too much time now
opponent searching for moves
ah oh so close so close oh I wanted to
put that on YouTube I'll probably still
reluctantly put that on YouTube good
game
I found a Stearman you can check out his
links in the chat I'll share I'll share
your twitch channel or your your chest
profile maybe I didn't have force mates
opponent found the one the one thing
drats does anyone say drafts anymore
maybe it's a UK thing on a social close
there's a v6 yeah it's not force me I
mean it's really good it looks like oh
it's plus it's only plus 1.4 really I
mean really bishop I mean Queen GeForce
so attractive that's crazy that this is
not winning okay computer eventually
find something Oh King f6 waking up 6
1998 King e6 wow it was tricky that rook
team won probably hard enough to play
and then I was worse that's so crazy I
probably should have taken the draw I
mean I thought that was gonna be meeting
I was dreaming of this and then this and
then this and then this and then this on
the net and then maybe this meets that
would be nice
oh that's life what should you know I
thought her video for you too